continuing with unsurprising coronavirus
news
schools of all kinds have started to
open elementary middle high school
colleges and universities
and coronavirus clusters are exploding
now i wish i could say
you know it really seemed like this
wasn't going to happen we're shocked by
this this was
it was just unpredictable we knew that
this was going to happen
a few stories from around the country at
purdue university
cases student cases on campus are
already at 41 within just a few days of
students
moving in remember that it often takes
five days to show symptoms
so certainly it's more than 41 cases
that will ultimately be discovered at
purdue university's campus
in florida nearly 9 000 kids have tested
positive in the two weeks since schools
reopened
that brings the total number of cases in
florida among those under 18 to close to
50 000 cases if you look across the
country you have about
750 colleges and universities now with
cases
university of north carolina is a bad
one they've had to send
all most undergraduate students home
already
it's not even september north carolina
had so many cases in the dorms that most
undergrads have already been sent home
notre dame is delaying classes because
dozens of students have tested positive
there
iowa state dozens of cases in the dorms
one of the worst
outbreaks is at the university of
alabama at birmingham
where there are nearly a thousand cases
university of central florida
750 cases i'm not going to give you the
whole list but it's everywhere and it
was completely predictable
now i want to remind everybody in the
audience because every time i talk about
this i get the same
confused emails i am not pretending
especially when it comes to school age
kids elementary middle school high
school
that this is a simple issue this is not
a simple issue you have parents who
can't work if their kids aren't in
school
you have parents that have jobs that you
can't work from home
but they don't pay enough to pay for
child care meaning it wouldn't make
sense
if their kids are at home to go to work
and pay for childcare they just can't
work they've got to stay home
that's a systemic problem with the
country
we've not done enough in terms of
stimulus compared to other countries
it is a complicated situation but it is
a systemic problem
you of course have parents who just
insist this is no big deal and want to
send their kids
to to school you have parents who
believe you know coronavirus conspiracy
theories you have all that stuff but the
real problem
is not so much parents choosing to send
their kids to school because they're not
worried about the virus
this is really a systemic problem that
has put
a lot of parents into untenable
situations
now that's different than colleges and
universities
we're talking about if things go
correctly you just need to do remote
learning in the fall
clearly this fall semester should be
done remote it should be done online
it should have been done from day one
some schools did it others have refused
to do it
we're not talking about forever and i
get that if you're an incoming freshman
this is not a fun way to start college
this is probably not even the best way
to start college from the perspective
of learning i get it but let's not
miss the forest for the trees having to
shut down a semester in progress
and send people home sometimes days
after the semester started it's way more
disruptive than just saying hey guys you
know
it sucks but we're going to do remote
for the fall and then hopefully in the
spring we can start to
to go back to normal spending the time
developing a good remote learning system
for the fall rather than bringing
students in
endless testing cases pop up sending
students home it would have made far
more sense
elementary middle high school i'm not
pretending it isn't complicated
the problems are more systemic than they
are individual
our federal government has failed quite
simply
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video